guys I don't know if you know this but
CS2 has a bit of a cheater problem it's
go trying to wall bang him across the
map he's like yo Olaf boost this
motherucker who what the was that
brother he put his Auto sniper on Burst
Mode this one Rob's posted 24 hours
Sydney connect with very talented
players oh this kid's really talented
holy sh wow nice shot brother
dude this kid has a sick gaming chair
yeah sick gaming chair pimp is right
they had a lot of time to prepare for
this launch we cannot allow people to
come in from valerin from pubg from Call
of Duty from anywhere and the first
experience they have with Counter-Strike
2 is a bunch of [__] idiots teating
their ass off I don't know why people
bought into the copium thinking that
like V live was somehow going to solve
this problem the only thing that is
surprising to me is that this is
surprising to anybody